[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Tina
joins us in Jacksonville Florida Tina
what's going
on hey thank you for having me on the
call uh so we are just starting the
program my husband and I and I threw a
very bad series of mistakes with car
trade car trade car trade and now in
serious negative equity and uh my
husband and I talked about it and we are
willing to do whatever it has to take to
you know we're going to sell the car um
we found a dealership that's willing to
buy it but we got to cover the negative
equity so I tried to take out a
signature loan through my credit union
and we were declined so now it's like
what do I do what's my next step do I
try to Devi up amongst credit cards do I
just bite the bullet and pay off this
car do I try and take a home equity loan
where do I where do I go well any option
that involves
moving the debt to other debt I I hate
that I have to tell you this is not
going to solve your
problem think about it like this you
have a bullet wound in one in your foot
shooting any other part of your body
will not fix that bullet wound in your
foot you got it so here's the here's the
options you have that don't involve debt
number one is you guys save up the
difference that you owe and then sell it
so you can cover the full amount that's
owed or uh you said you got declined at
that credit union have you tried others
did they tell you the reason is it due
to your credit
score credit score okay so your credit
score is shot because of was there
delinquent payments um no uh over
utilization okay we with our house and
all of our credit were're about half a
million in debt oh my goodness how much
Consumer Debt do you guys have
serious I'm sorry how much Consumer Debt
debt do you have outside of the mortgage
um we have 127 in credit card 127 in
credit
cards yeah 127,000 in credit cards what
did you put on these
cards um stuff for the house helping out
our kids um vacations that we shouldn't
have gone on what's the interest rate on
these U the majority of them you know
they vary between 12 and
18% what what about this situation I'm
I'm asking you this not to beat you up
but I I I really want to know where your
where your psychology
is you're half a million dollars in
debt the fact that you're considering
trying to clean up some of your debt
issues with more
debt like at what point does it stop for
you
it has to stop right because um we want
to retire in five years and we know it's
not possible right if we don't change
and so I'm willing to you know do
whatever it takes what's your household
income listen to a couple of the shows
um and you know um Dave had said take
out a personal loan to pay off the
equity sell that car get a beater car
you know lower your debt total debt so
that's what I thought we could do but it
does doesn't seem like and I don't trust
my own decisions clearly because if I
did I wouldn't be here so what is your
household
income uh monthly we bring we bring in
monthly we bring in about
13,000 okay good and what is your total
minimum payments on all of the debt that
you have Consumer
Debt total minimum payments is
monthly
um going to go grab it um about
4700 okay are you able to put an extra
th000 2,000 3,000 4,000 on top of that
to pay it
off that's what we were going to do you
know starting with the the smallest
first um but considering I owe almost
80,000 on this car we thought we could
get out of you know get rid of it and
that would take a huge chunk out how
much upside down are
you about 20 2,000 and are you sure of
that because you said the dealership
said they'd buy it for this amount well
the dealership's going to lowball you
comparatively to a private party
sale so I haven't tried private party um
the car the balance we owe is about
80,000 and when I go through Kelly Blue
Book um it's between 55 and 60 is the
value and the car dealership is offering
US 58 because it's a 20 23 with really
low miles on
it okay well we want to get as much for
this car as we can to shrink that Gap do
you guys have any money in the
bank just
$1,000 okay you have anything in your
home you could sell
yeah um we've thought about that you
know like I said we're just getting
started and we can start you know like
selling off and start making my list of
things that I could get rid of I'm
talking tools guitars motorcycles you
guys sound like you bought some stuff
with those credit cards jet skis
everything no nothing tangible that's
worth anything more than like household
goods I'm at the point now I'm willing
to sell my wedding set if that would get
us out of debt what is the house
worth the house um is worth if we go by
Zillow because I don't have the Cs but
if we go by Zillow it's worth about
424 and what do you owe on the mortgage
273 okay and what was your total
Consumer Debt load I had cut you off
What's the total of all the Consumer
Debt
combined of everything is not including
the house
233 okay this might be the car and
student loans and credit cards this
might be one of those situations where
you make the ultimate sacrifice of
selling the house you'll clear about 150
maybe 130 after fees and that gets you
down to 100,000 in debt but also 20
20,000 of that you sell that car and
that knocks off another 80 off the
total and what happens then is you're
going to have to rent for a while it may
be a long time how old are you at least
you can get out of
this I'm 59
okay it
um when my mom went back to school she
got her tenure Professor job at the age
of 57 she just retired in her mid
70s that may that not it's not May
that's 100% what you're looking at okay
you're going to have to go find a job
and you'reall just going to have to work
and scratch and Claw consider selling
the house even if it's just let's Sprint
and get this 20,000 bucks to get rid of
this let's just do that let's go ahead
and list it private sale just to see
what happens too I there's something the
fact that a dealership would offer you
more than Kelly Bluebook doesn't doesn't
register with me but I don't know enough
about the car or anything like that it
doesn't sound right but maybe maybe um
and then you and your husband have to
decide are we going to get one two or
three or four jobs do we want this no I
don't see a picture we all retire in
five years I just don't and so I think
the quicker you can you can grieve that
that and say we wanted this to be the
case but it's not going to be let's
shoot for 75 instead of
65 um then you're going to it's going to
give you a little gas in in the tank and
y'all just got to knock this thing out F
like item by item by item it will not be
how you drew it up and you have to you
have to commit to taking debt off the
table it can never be an option for you
ever ever
ever agreed I'm so sorry I'm sorry you
got to learn this in this way Tina we're
going to send you a Financial Peace
University it sounds like you're new to
Our Gang we're going to send it to you
we're going to send you for a year the
premium version of every dollar it's
going to help you and your husband get
aligned to do something youall have
never done before which is make a budget
and make money decisions together create
your free every dollar budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life